SPEAKER 1: Hi, Martin.
What are you doing?
MARTIN: I'm trying to post
a cat video to CatTube,
but there is a bug.
I filed an issue on
GitHub yesterday,
but they haven't responded yet.
I wonder if there's a
way to alert their dev
team when new issues are filed.
SPEAKER 1: Sounds like
a good job for Webhooks.
Stay tuned if you'd
like to know more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Katie is a developer at CatTube.
She wants to ensure
that if someone files
an issue in GitHub,
her team is notified
and the issue isn't
lost in her inbox.
And honestly, we try
to read all emails,
but those are just
good intentions.
Luckily, GitHub is one
of the many services that
provides event-driven Webhooks.
What this means is that
if someone files an issue,
Github will send a request to a
URL specified by the developer.
MARTIN: Katie can use Cloud Run
to host the new Webhook target.
This means she won't have
to worry about servers,
and she can use the
language and framework
she's comfortable with.
SPEAKER 1: The first thing
Katie has to worry about
is authorization.
A Webhook target is a public
URL, and anyone with the URL
could send anything to it.
To ensure she's only
processing valid requests,
Katie uses a shared secret.
Katie creates a
secret key and puts
one copy in the GitHub
configuration and stores
a copy securely with the
Cloud Secret Manager.
Every request from
GitHub is signed,
so Katie uses the secret
to validate the signature
and only processes
the valid requests.
MARTIN: That's great, but how
does this help alert her team?
SPEAKER 1: Well, now that she's
able to securely receive events
from GitHub, Katie will use
these events to send messages
to Slack.
Katie already knows how
to use the Slack API,
so she writes a function to send
a message to her team's Slack
channel every time a
valid request from GitHub
is received.
Her team will never
miss another issue.
MARTIN: Katie also
wants the users
to know that her team
is working on the issue.
Using the same Webhook,
she writes a function
to post an order response
back to the GitHub issue.
SPEAKER 1: Finally, she wants
to measure how long it takes
her team to close an issue.
She adds one more
function to her Webhook
to stream any issue events
to BigQuery so she can easily
create metrics around her
team's issue performance.
The full Webhook target is
now creating notifications,
triggering an action, and
streaming data into BigQuery.
Katie was happy to solve
all three of her issues
using Webhooks on Cloud Run.
She gave me a $1 bill.
How many GitHub issues
would that process for her?
MARTIN: Cloud Run pricing
is based primarily
on the number of requests
and gigabyte-seconds used.
Each bug filed in
GitHub will trigger
one request, which will take
Cloud Run about one second
to process.
Each request will
stream a row of data
into BigQuery of
about one kilobyte.
Katie will get 2 million
Cloud Run requests for free
but will be slightly over the
free tier on gigabyte usage.
Her total Cloud Run
bill will be $0.78.
For streaming and storing
the rows of one kilobyte each
to BigQuery, Katie
will pay $0.13.
So that $1 bill would let
her process 2 million bugs in
a month, with a little
change to spare.
SPEAKER 1: That's a lot of bugs.
MARTIN: Tune in
next time to see how
Katie can set up a more robust
and fault-tolerant Webhook
using Pub/Sub.
[MUSIC PLAYING]